this morning we are getting a look at a
new documentary that examines american
policies and opinions before during and
after the holocaust the u.s and the
holocaust is co-directed by ken burns
lynn novak and sarah botstein and in the
clip you're about to see
you can see how easily a society can
change and the vital lesson we can all
learn from the holocaust
the fragility
of civilized behavior is the one thing
you really learn
because these people who we now see in
these photographs these sepia
photographs and they're receding into
time they're no different
no different from us
you look at your neighbors the people at
the dry cleaners the waiters in the
restaurant that's who these people were
don't kid yourself
we have seen the nation of human
behavior and we have no guarantee
that it won't recur
if we can make that clear
and graphic
and understandable
not as
something to imitate but as a warning
of what can happen to human beings
then perhaps
we have one shield
against its recurrence
and ken burns and lynn novak join us now
that is such a well chosen clip because
it is so true we want to imagine that we
if we were alive then would be the
heroes the ones that stood up the ones
who shouted and yet the documentaries
about how we as a country had that
opportunity and clearly did not shout
loud enough let's say
the important thing
we're not responsible for the holocaust
we let in more people than any other
sovereign nation but we didn't do
anywhere near enough what we could even
if we fulfilled the pernicious and tiny
quotas we could have had five times as
many people rescued from the holocaust
we could have shouted louder our public
leaders could have done that the
congress could have revoked some of
these uh terrible immigration
anti-immigration laws the american
public could have woken up to the
evidence that they were seeing from the
very beginning of hitler's regime and
said you know what
who we are is a nation of immigrants
we've been built on the strength that
immigrants add and we should try to get
as many people in we did none of those
things and then when the u.s tried to
shout and criticize they would say well
wait a second what are you doing in your
own country
they would point to mississippi for
instance and jim crow could you talk
about that yes i never thought about
that before until looking at your doctor
yeah so so hitler and the nazis
instituted something called the
nuremberg laws and early in the regime
to basically take away jewish people's
rights of the of their country and they
used our jim crow laws as a model so
they came here and they studied how we
had created a whole legal structure jim
crow to make sure that african americans
did not have the full rights of
citizenship and they were very aware of
everything we were doing and they used
it as a model and so when we would
criticize them and say wait you're
persecuting the jews they would turn
around and say back back america and you
should have some very graphic images of
that too
yeah that they're hard to look at but
it's important for us as americans to
see some of the dark parts of our own
story as well we were swept up by a
thing called eugenics which was the
pseudoscience that was an attempt to
sort of make a hierarchy of races and
ethnicities there's only one race and
that's the human race and the fact is is
that this was became very popular
started in britain very popular in the
united states people subscribed to it
across the board he said people-minded
feeble-minded criminals criminals and
the idea was that you would force the
sterilization of people among many
aspects of eugenics right eugenics is
the mostly the most insidious thing is
the characterization of superior races
which hitler would borrow in this aryan
idea but it's also the idea that you
would force the sterilization of of of
disabled people and of people who had
mental uh differences and all of that
sort of stuff those laws were still in
the books in 2016. and that's now the
thing laws this is not a fringe idea no
no taught in schools this was passed by
elected bodies yeah you know it was
preached from uh pulpits
we just have to own what we
what our part is obviously we played an
important part in ending the second
world war but we also have to understand
the roles in which we stood by when we
could have helped at every level
and both are true and that's that's the
thing that the exceptionalism that we
have has to come with if you're going to
be exceptional you have to be
self-critical as well you have to look
in the mirror and see that reflection
that's right and identify with that
duality um this documentary was
originally supposed to end in 1965 with
the shift in u.s immigration policy why
did you feel like it was important to
bring it all the way up until present
day
as we were working on the film we've
been working on it for the last seven
years events around us we could see the
echoes and the parallels between what
was happening during the 1930s in europe
and here and was happening all around us
and we saw
things that we felt we needed to sort of
pull the thread all the way through to
the present and so yes we did rectify
some of the pernicious immigration laws
in 1965 but the sort of stream of racism
and anti-semitism and bigotry is still
part of our society as we know and the
threat of authoritarianism and the
danger of our democracy being under
siege the you know free and fair
elections yeah let me take that for
granted
we wanted to join the conversation right
now there was an urgency this film was
supposed to come out next year but we
accelerated the process the great
holocaust scholar deborah lipstadt in
the film says the time to stop a
genocide is before it happens the time
to save a democracy is before it's lost
and that it's incumbent upon us to go
and say look if you wanted to be in the
hippest place you know most vibrant in
arts in 1930 and 31 and 32 would be
berlin and then the next year
not so much
we thank you both because they're saying
less than 30 seconds we have to go
because ken i just want to say something
about your look you have a new look
we all remember you from the beatles
days this new look you're trying you're
doing well you know tom brokaw from
another network told me that i needed to
get a big boy haircut and so i finally
after about eight or nine years of
temporizing and kicking all grown up
[Laughter]
we'll be right back thank you